[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente desde casa
en france24 esta semana dedicamos el
programa a hablar de la desertificación
de las tierras y qué significa eso pues
básicamente consiste en la degradación
paulatina de terrenos fértiles ubicados
en zonas semi secas o secas que terminan
por convertirse en suelos áridos y no
productivos es un fenómeno que afecta al
40 por ciento de la población del
planeta y el principal causante de ello
adivinen nosotros los humanos algunas de
las mayores causas son la deforestación
intencional ya sea para obtener madera o
para cultivar o explotar el terreno
también el pastoreo intensivo de
animales que hace que las plantas no
puedan regenerarse a tiempo y se
erosione el suelo o la agricultura
intensiva que agota los nutrientes de la
tierra en américa latina y
particularmente en la amazonía la
deforestación es uno de los mayores
motores de desertificación entrevisté a
miguel pacheco coordinador de recursos
naturales y medios de vida y
especialista forestal de wwf colombia él
nos dio más información sobre qué zonas
se ven más afectadas por esta práctica
a inicios de este año lanzó un reporte
global sobre los procesos de
deforestación
e identifica que aproximadamente del año
2004 al año 2017 se deforestaron un
total de 43 millones de hectáreas esto
para tener una referencia es
aproximadamente el área de marruecos o
para aterrizar en latinoamérica es el
área aproximadamente de paraguay
dentro de este reporte identifica 24
frentes de deforestación en el mundo y 9
de estos es decir casi el 40% están en
latinoamérica
evidentemente gran parte de esto
aproximadamente cifra entre
deforestación están en la amazonía y los
otros están en otras zonas boscosas como
por ejemplo el choco arin la selva maya
cerrado brasilero entre otros entonces
lo que vemos aquí es que hay un gran
avance de los procesos de deforestación
en la región y con esto a través de las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
se incrementa la temperatura y esto lo
que hace es acelerar los procesos de
desertificación en la región
pacheco también nos explicó
de los impactos en la región recordemos
que la amazonía juega un rol importante
a través de las emisiones que tiene de
ola evapora la evapotranspiración de
agua emitida a la atmósfera que está a
su vez a través de ríos voladores como
se le llama en el argot técnico llevan
el agua hacia las cordilleras de los
andes y éstas riegan los cultivos para
los alimentos que vienen a las mesas
principalmente en la región a su vez
esta agua es la que abastece a las
grandes ciudades al momento que se da
los procesos de desertificación estos
bosques dejan de cumplir esas tareas y
pues lamentablemente se reducen los
caudales de agua lamentablemente los
cultivos que llegan a nuestra mesa
también pues no son posibles no se
pueden dar
al no tener lluvias que lleguen hacia
las cordilleras de los andes entonces
todos esos procesos si esto continúa se
van a seguir dando y lamentablemente en
nuestros estilos de vida van a cambiar
eventualmente vamos a tener que
aprovechar otro tipo de recursos para
alimentarnos y buscar otros medios para
conseguir
realmente creo que tenemos que ponerle y
darle bastante importancia a estos
procesos esto acá es urgente es urgente
y sinceramente trabajo mucho en campo y
veo día a día en los procesos de
degradación y deforestación y preocupa
bastante que esto no se le esté dando la
importancia debida precisamente para
orientar la atención hacia esta
problemática global cada 17 de junio se
celebra el día de lucha contra la
desertificación y la sequía costa rica-
primer país tropical que logró revertir
la degradación de bosques y que cuenta
ahora con una tasa de cobertura forestal
de más del 52 por ciento de su
territorio quiso mandar un mensaje para
incentivar a los gobiernos a que
financien la restauración de casi mil
millones de hectáreas degradadas a nivel
global una superficie equivalente a
china que muchas veces esos servicios
que dan los bosques o los sistemas
agroforestales que generalmente los
tienen comunidades rurales muchas
mujeres comunidades indígena
son servicios no sólo a la propia
comunidad sino a todo el planeta en
alimentación en protección de especies
en protección de suelos en
y capturar carbono y cada vez más esos
servicios que históricamente se han dado
de gratis que disfruta toda la humanidad
tienen que ser considerados y tienen que
llegar esos recursos a los países
particularmente pobres o de renta media
que hacen esos esfuerzos es una forma de
solidaria global que también tenemos que
implementar y costa rica ha llevado
ejemplos que nos interesa también que
otros países vean para demostrar que si
es posible esa recuperación de suelos de
bosques y que es posible también hacerlo
de una manera ambientalmente sostenible
y económicamente sostenible y es que la
erosión y la degradación de suelos no
sólo se reflejará en menos agua y menos
comida disponible sino que tendrá
consecuencias negativas en la
biodiversidad del planeta creará pobreza
y causará migraciones forzadas y además
empeorará los impactos y aumentará la
incidencia de fenómenos climáticos como
inundaciones o huracanes por el
contrario la restauración de tierras
degradadas es una solución ambiental
social y económica crea
empleo y aumentaría los ingresos
recuperaría la biodiversidad de la zona
y también reduciría las cantidades de
carbono emitidas a la atmósfera algo que
ralentizaría el calentamiento global y
por ende el cambio climático un objetivo
que se pretende cumplir durante el
decenio de las naciones unidas sobre la
restauración de los ecosistemas que
inició este 2021 es todo por esta semana
hay más medio ambiente en france24 punto
com
[Música]